hi slugs listen to today's episode if
you want to hear what TV show we're
gonna be the pioneers of as first guests
on and we're manifesting that was the
wordiest way of saying it but you guys
get it thank you
um Annie and I are doing stand-up we
want you to come see us we're having so
much fun and I this month I'm going to
be in Chicago Minneapolis Denver and
then I'm coming to Austin get tickets at
astronauts.com and my sleepover drop
should be out by now I'm wearing one of
the new shirts says do not resuscitate
Sleepover by esther.com what's up
sluggies I am so excited to be on the
road and meeting all of you the meet and
greets are epic I cannot believe it
please come see me I have new merch
coming that is wild some sunnies some
socks this weekend I'm going to be in
San Jose California we rocked it out in
San Francisco so I cannot wait to see
you guys again there I'm gonna be in
Dania Beach Florida I'll be in Omaha
Nebraska St Louis Missouri Houston Texas
Burbank California West Nyack New York
Austin Texas Texas Springfield Missouri
Homestead PA Tempe Arizona Colusa
California Kansas City Irvine there's a
billion other ones please go to
annieleterman.com shows you cannot miss
it everything's crazy it's a freaking
party can't wait to see you there
[Music]
how is everybody today Annie is this day
one of your egg Journey no it's tomorrow
I had one last coffee oh wait so what is
this tell us your one last of everything
guys it's been like it's been like
almost a month of one last I have been
well because I knew okay so I knew
Whitney told me that I was going to be
like four months pregnant what which by
the way the doctor was like he was like
she did get she did get bloated he like
left but it's I don't think that that's
necessarily the case we'll see I'll be
the guinea pig for us all but so
everyone if you don't already know and
he's getting her eggs frozen
this is a huge can you guys do a thing
where it shoots eggs out
and then kalila catches them in her
mouth catch it Esther
make it crack on her face
I'll look it up it's go go she loves it
um yellow go go no will eggs probably
have nutrients
you eating eggs no I'm like fully on
board I'm gonna feed you just want to be
clear by the way this is not just eggs
we are competing with our own sponsors
um but okay so
they put me on birth control and what I
think they put me on birth control for
was so that they could time around my
tour schedule when they started I don't
know if they would just go with a
natural cycle usually so I did like two
weeks of birth control and they gave me
like a CH they checked my uterus and my
my ovaries
first time I went in then I did birth
control I went in what you have a uterus
do you believe it it's just so weird
it's a meteorous I am very very
narcissistic
sorry guys
um it was fun having bird on and just
trying to I don't think I told you ahead
of time but I was gonna see if I could
interrupt more than he interrupts and
talk over him more and I was unable to
I was unable to do it anyway Kyle looks
10 by the way 10 or 10. the the way
she's sitting and you look so young in
your skin
it's very glowy it's very you there's a
youth glow really yeah well I went back
to SoulCycle today it's my first workout
since covid and let me tell you uh my
performance was not great that's okay so
shout out to Diego if you ever want to
take the Diego class I'll do it with you
do you feel like you ever come out of
there feeling like you did your best yes
I am when it comes to working out I am a
charger 100 I never phoned it in I am
somebody that if I'm gonna commit my
time to a workout I'm gonna go all out
and this is why Kyle and I get along
so funny about this is that Esther
literally asked her her workout
instructor to do a time slot she's never
done in her life like how much was it
half hour oh she every person does like
an hour and Esther's like can we bring
it down to 20 minutes my trainer
invented the 30 minute session for me
wait a second speaking of Kyle so she
texted me two weeks ago and she
um did her very first berries okay and
she walked out of there and she was
crying in her car and I was like what's
the matter who was the instructor and it
was good Kyle you're abusive in all the
right ways we love you you're abusive
and waiting I love so gorgeous this Gap
ads with his I don't know if he's
married is that he's married yeah he's
married and the music he plays is so
good it's so good it's so hot I'm like
also how dare you be that hot and not
for us I want to have you that's like
all the berries instructors there's a
guy named Donald
I swear to you I've never seen you are a
beautiful man
I know Donald doesn't seem like a hot
guy but I'm telling you pull Donald from
Barry's please
Donald when I was 19. yes I did I did
well I'm here to tell you there are hot
Donald's he had strap-up pants he had
jeans with like laced up they laced up
the crotch oh it was like like Christina
Aguilera yes
are you sure he wasn't Donny I might
have been the last
vagina yes that's Donald okay he's
obviously hot yeah he's very hot now I
had a berries uh egg related Berry
situation so I just manically one night
recently because I've been eating so
shitty yeah wait I want to hear all okay
so we'll just do it and see yes okay
so I um they put me on the birth control
and birth control actually sent me
through a sales I'm never I never do
birth control because it makes me like
crazy I don't like them [ __ ] with my
hormones all that stuff but I had to do
it for two weeks
yeah it wasn't the whole cycle oh that's
what I'm saying like I think they were
just trying to get me at a very specific
yeah so it would be the beginning of my
cycle when we start the thing
so I um because you know you get your
period guys you might I know this if you
miss your one [ __ ] moment of your
birth control you gush blood and really
it's a nightmare correct but so for
someone with ADD I had to stop doing
birth control because I was like I'm
just gonna have my period every other
day I'm gonna forget this all the time
but so um
so one of the birth control was
emotionally eating I don't know why it
made me eat so much I just I think no
that's normal yeah but [ __ ] with your
hormones in ways you don't understand
but I remember when I started birth
control again like when I was in my 20s
the binge eating was
award-winning and you were hanging out
with Benji so it's Benji eating
Benji loves to push a little bin
they bought you all the dessert
he's the opposite of Carlos that's so
true it's actually the opposite of
Carlos but so
um so I just was eating a lot and I was
like you know what I'm just gonna like
pretend I'm pregnant and just like use
this time to just eat a lot I know I'm
gonna have to I know I'm gonna get
bloated anyway
so I was like eating like shed and you
know having fun doing it and then in the
middle of the night I was like you know
what
I gotta come back hard I'm gonna sign up
for berries I'm gonna start doing
berries so then I sign up for berries of
course I do like the 280 where it's like
three three classes a week which I'm
like that is so crazy to go full
barriers three berries a week is a lot
that's what I used to do but I did
always get injured I'm not gonna lie
sorry Bears you know what no offense to
you it's probably my bad I once
purchased like at once like a hundred
classes like by the end of the year I
was trying to beg them if I could
exchange it for 50 points I think you're
the reason why when when a new client
comes in comes in now you're the reason
why they're always like why don't you do
one um one class before you sign up for
more classes they they have to say that
now and I think you're it yeah I lost
thousands of dollars like think going
for that trick and listen I like losing
money so I would be into that but Esther
does not like it no it was painful they
were precious though I love berries
they're really amazing so okay so I
order I order the classes and then I
immediately see Dr Wong in my head going
you're not going to be able to exercise
you can only do like light walking and
stuff and I go wait why did I just sign
up for the monthly thing from that time
when I just can't do it so I wrote them
I wrote them I go guys I'm freezing my
eggs I'm such a like dildo I'm sorry I
am an idiot like I just completely
forgot I was like once my eggs are
frozen I'm like so excited to come back
but I just this is the two weeks I'm
unable to exercise so
um they wrote me back they were so nice
like we totally understand we refunded
it like hit us up oh that's good I know
I was like so happy but I did put my
Instagram handle yeah I do always go
this is my Instagram handle I signed
with like my if you want to follow my
egg Journey no just like my number of
followers and just like sliding 20
across the table like you don't want to
[ __ ] with this I'm so annoying
just watch some clips you don't want to
get involved I like that it's not about
being famous or having followers it's
just like I'm annoying check it out
you're not gonna get rid of me Crunch
Gym has been like kind of [ __ ] with
me and by the way they haven't stopped
[ __ ] with me so here we go it's gonna
get annoying Crunch Gym you're going to
prison crunch can you arrest Crunch Gym
what is he like the what's theirs can
you bring up Crunch Gym I want to see
what their um logo is it's been a while
since I've been there they've been
charging me since they re crunch ship
can you can I put that's the word crunch
is there low can I put the fist that's
holding the crunch in a handcuff
there should be shackles hanging down
there should be shackles hanging down
these people are criminals during the
pandemic when I was four okay
um Okay so
they in the middle of the pandemic when
I'm broke as [ __ ] I'm like literally
Esther and I were like
anyway we were manifest we're
manifesting let's just say we were I was
doing the man she was doing the best
thing
we were manifesting ourselves we had
nothing to do it was a wild time
um but anyway so
they just turned my account back on
I had a frozen account that they just
turned back on and started charging me
and they have not stopped charging me
I'm like I will not pay you guys a
dollar and my credit card I didn't know
until that credit card got um I didn't
know until my true bill that they were
still charging me so they're charging me
and then it's on an old card so they're
just hitting this old card and it's not
getting any money because the card got
canceled so now they're just now that's
on them but now they're writing me
complaining that I owe them all this
back money I'm like why would I owe you
money when you turned my account back on
without you without telling me send me
an email and I didn't say you did not
get my consent to turn it back on you
cannot turn it back on they're doing
this to so many other people they're
doing this to a million people and the
problem is that like if it was an active
card you could just dispute the charges
I you could let them know hey like these
are yeah you have a case here yeah and
don't we all trash Tuesday have a case
here
I have an army now an army of slugs that
will very slowly swear them in front of
you and
anyway don't go to Crunch Gym they
[ __ ] suck go to any other gym they're
[ __ ] blow well that's what Kyle
always says really yeah well not crunch
sometimes he uses crunch as an example
but he's always like
you're not here because you like Planet
Fitness like he always like
um so if you don't want to be here walk
two blocks down the street to Planet
Fitness is that what it's called planet
shitness is what my dad calls it but he
says things like that that make me like
feel even more honored to be under his
um abusive um you know I can't wait to
get just beat up by him I'm really so
excited I have a pitch and we're gonna
get back tracks because I of course no
you're the in charge I have 80d yes
Barry's hires us no ambassadors no it's
way less she just wants a smoothie she's
like I want one free Smoothie you really
are Bobby you know that right he only
goes in for the smoothies oh my God it's
actually so funny it's like I go to the
movie theater sometimes just to get
popcorn yeah yeah yes oh my God I have
done that I've gone to the mall gone to
the movie theaters get the popcorn walk
around the mall yeah it's dropping it
all over the place I have to go into a
Bed Bath and Beyond and just drop them
like use your brooms we can follow each
other find each other oh my God I would
go to Skokie can we can we play that
you're doing that you do the what's what
was the Korean bow you do the Korean bow
while you're licking it up she's just
frogging around the ground
wait is there a BBB there BBB but that's
beyond I was just there like two weeks
ago like that so confidently that we
were 20 off entire purchase guys I have
coupons guys
I got the buzz yesterday I got the buzz
the alert that I got a text and I went
I got my 20 off but is it for the item
or is it for the entire purchase but how
many things do I need okay okay all my
hens are clucking in the end speaking of
eggs
okay I think we should all together go
take Kyle's class like it's so obvious
right we have to do it yes okay great
yeah okay thousand percent Carlos fire
up the uh Annie's Tesla and let's go oh
fire it up don't actually fire it up
it's hard to get out once it's on fire
you get [ __ ] guys there is a chance
Teslas are amazing cards and then every
once in a while you burn to death but
you know oh God not me not me not me I
know I did my Syracuse promo video and
it's about me burning to nothing
okay just kidding Elon can't wait to
come to your parties Joe don't [ __ ] this
up we're gonna go to Kyle's class eggs
Carlos I am curious what are you how
high are you not here the clicking is
hilarious I took a 100 milligram edible
like an hour ago so we'll see how are
you right now like just like like seven
ten percent yeah like I'm in it
yeah wait did I tell you guys when I
took the ate the Doritos and I was
eating the weed Doritos and then I'm
talking to Todd I got weed Doritos when
I was in um what are wheat Doritos in
Richmond I was like I need weed I like
didn't know where to get weed so this
guy brought me all of these
all of these different types of weeds
and they had one that was it was this
bag of Doritos it's like dusted with
weed and I was like oh amazing so I'm on
the phone after the show talking to Todd
I'm just like just shoving them down
they're so good they're delicious and
then he's like how many milligrams are
they look at how six is a hundred oh
no what happened I puked I made myself
puke I was like I can't go through this
journey I'm not ready to have a [ __ ]
I don't want to die I don't have an ego
death
wow so you can make yourself puke to
like as an emergency I pulled the
trigger you can't duster I tried sadly I
tried and I was never able to I just
binged I never purged okay I'm a big
purger major major like I what yeah even
blow jobs
did you guys get boners that was really
nice
let's just say I've thrown up on a few
cops myself yeah your extra lube they
love that when you look up and you're
all like just you know look so just
broken and you're crying there's a
little like piece of baloney on YouTube
where the baloney come from the baloney
was the sandwich let's go back to
talking about eggs oh really are you
sure we don't want to talk about people
still eating bologna I just I have an
image when we were little okay when I
was in Nursery School we had those
remember the boots that were like the
hyper color boots and they would like
when you would go out into the snow they
would turn into colors we had those
little like Moon snow boots that we
would wear outside and I just remember
it was either I threw up or my brother
threw up on my boots and it was all
baloney and so now whenever I just
imagine Bologna's in it
dude College I used to just fry bologna
oh that's good yeah it was batter
Hamburger Helper I remember mushroom
crackers I ate bologna for my school
lunches and I got made fun of once and
it really traumatizes what did they say
about like ew baloney and I was like
baloney
you're right it's a lie I um I would
always like fold it up and then you bite
the thing off and then you like had an
eye and you look like oh you don't say
bologna baloney
um in the studio today this is a perfect
opportunity to just make eyeballs
baloney sunglasses could have been a
thing and we could make the hole then
you could [ __ ] the hold the baloney I'm
out on that Carlos isn't Carlos was
thinking about it he was like What if
yeah I was like trying to figure it out
it just seems like too high like the
baloney instantly wouldn't you no you
make the hole yeah but going through the
hole wouldn't like feel good to have
like because you need it to be tighter
you need it to be tighter to feel it and
then that would tear it I don't think my
[ __ ] is very tight I'm like thinking
about it none of us do okay no one's out
here thinking I'm just kidding you know
what I mean
but it is funny you do know most of my
jokes are are just there's a word that I
can say that I know will make people
laugh it's not necessarily like I mean
I've seen some semen on your back but we
have
um I just don't think um so you know
when Bert was talking about being you
know like very afraid to be with um
sexual partners because he was afraid of
getting STDs yeah so the truth about me
is I'm kind of just they used to call me
a face Queen because I actually wouldn't
my body count is not very high but the
amount of dudes I've blown is very high
like exponentially higher than the dudes
I've actually had sex with and that's
because I had that same thing where I
was like very conscious about like STDs
there's a natural loosening that happens
it's over time a little bit is there
like uh
okay I actually think girls that [ __ ]
more have tighter [ __ ] really well
they're cute yeah you're using your
muscles more
huh I love when gay guys Express how
like rip pulse they are my vaginas it's
a relief I don't like that really yeah
no I think that's fun why because it's
still shaming a woman's body part like
and you know there's gay men that hate
women so it to me I'm okay with it as
long as I can just shame the [ __ ] out of
yours I don't as long as we're in a
shame equal shaming I'm fine but I do
feel like I'm I take back the night
sometimes talking [ __ ] on decks on stage
where it's like because it is like how
often I'd [ __ ] hear that [ __ ] and
then it's like and then you like get
older and you get open with your
partners and stuff and all your partners
are like like every boyfriend I was like
you have like a great [ __ ] like that
and I'm like wow all this time I spent
but I'm actually glad I think having
um being worried about my vagina
made me less of a hoe that's awesome but
being I wouldn't be like in I feel like
being a hoe for me is a real badge of
honor I was really ashamed for sucking a
lot of dick when I was young because
that's much more meant for sucking
exactly thank you finally it would be
rude wasted potential if I didn't spend
my life just sucking dick I used to love
sucking dick guys I'm it's a wrap for me
yeah TMJ honestly I know where the TMJ I
do it but I'm never gonna pretend I used
to like it it used to like get me off to
like just blow guys have suck a dick day
where it would be like this power move
or be like a guy that I like I swear to
God and I loved it like I would just
like show up at a guy's house I'd be
like um
and I would just blow if they tried to
[ __ ] I'd be like ew This is like a dick
day do not disrespect the rule excuse me
you guys let's talk about Bessie I'm
sick of clunky shoes I want lightweight
shoes breathable breathable I want
cruelty free I want vegan waterproof
snow proof the person who's never had
snow in their life I've been in snow
three times no wow if you haven't heard
of Bessie listen up because we're newly
obsessed it's sustainably made and it's
vegan and they are comfortable
lightweight and breathable and they're
actually really stylish they are and
they're snow proof for winter like you
the fact that you have a sneaker you can
wear in winter that's that light is
unbelievable it just I it made me
realize that like all I have are
sneakers and I needed something that was
more durable that I could actually use
like if there was ever like kind of
weird weather you know and also we
travel a lot right like having to pack
heavy clunky shoes in your suitcase
that's such a good point like honestly
when you go on the road and you go in
Winter to anywhere where they actually
have winter it's so infuriating it's
like you can't you're half your bag is
your boots right well with vesi you can
avoid all that because they're very
light and easy to travel with they're
also made from diametex
a dual climate knit material which keeps
you cool and summer and warm in winter
like if you think about it these are
like anything with them any weather any
climate vessies are our go-to shoes by
our doors check them out at the link
below bestie.com for a pair of your
vessi shoes thank you Bessie for
sponsoring this pod
only rules criteria had to be it had to
be someone that I had like been sexy
with before yeah I know so it was like
kind of already like placed like it was
it wasn't just like random doorbell with
the big like how they surprise you for
the Publishing Clearinghouse
here but there's a hole it's over my
mouth
I'm like hey guys it's a helpful Honda
dealers
helper Humber givers
but I just like and I loved it I loved
the power of like getting guys off like
it was so fun for me but I just now I'm
just I mean I guess I could get into
that no I guess there are times where
I'm like I'm gonna suck my man's dick
but it's just like I used to just wake
up like I would never know the day
before it was gonna be suck a dick day
so you just wake up what are the signs
that it might be a second dick day just
like this like this like Brewing
confidence here like it's just you're
like is that heartburn no suck a dick
day baby
oh that was fun and then you just leave
oh there's no touchy backs but then I
started to get I started no touchy back
no touchy back it feels like a a
sentence you invented be because you
know me no touchy backs no we were put
on this Earth to cut you back to have
those correspondence we have
sometimes I try to not um make fun of
you or interrupt you and I see your
little eyes looking over at me they're
little eyes you're like is it where is
it
wait I want to know about egg freezing
in this hour at some point we've gotta
you know get on the journey I'm not like
pretending to have 80 Duty what do you
mean oh you like don't want to talk
about it no just saying I have 80d oh I
would I can't wait to talk about it I
just have to everything reminds me of
another thing okay I need help let's go
back okay did the birth control ate a
bunch of food went crazy
taking the we're doing all this stuff
um I'm getting a little bloated we
stopped the birth I stopped the birth
control I go and I'm like like a little
bit starting my period they check
they're like all of your eggs are good I
have like 18 follicles on one side I
can't remember how many but like tons of
follicles so they're like this is really
good and then so they so then I got all
my meds I ordered the meds and they all
have a lot of them have to be Frozen and
you have to like mix all these things
it's like very weird there's a pen you
you inject and on a syringe but you have
to like add these powders to the syringe
and stuff so that was a little confusing
but I start those tomorrow and so that's
when they said you're not going to do a
lot of exercise and I asked him to
because I was like I am performing
throughout this whole thing I'm gonna be
on stage I'm gonna he's like you're
gonna be uncomfortable but we'll just
put you on a diet that's gonna make you
the least uncomfortable so in what way
um are you going to be uncomfortable I
think I'm gonna just be bloated and like
think about it it's like they're making
your body usually only makes like a few
they're making you have the most eggs
that you can have so it's gonna be like
more than you would have ever had
like so you know what I mean so they
tell you about like mood changes or like
hunger changes or sleep changes or just
bloating they just said I'm gonna be
uncomfortable okay yeah and it's only
for two weeks it's around two weeks and
then and it's great he like timed it
around my schedule it's like so cool and
um but so they said don't do any like
crazy cardio or you're jumping or
whatever I'm just gonna walk I'm gonna
do the Esther workout the hardcore
Esther workout I might not do it as hard
to do the Esther sometimes shoots ahead
you're like where is this [ __ ] I know I
always surprise people with how fast I
walk for how short my legs are like I
know and for like how much you're like
moving your hips back and forth bottling
it's the fastest waddling down but you
have surprisingly long legs for being um
very petite for being a little person
yeah like your proportions are very like
like normal yeah if you were five foot
ten you'd you know you'd have like Gigi
Hadid oh my God
yeah what I said on um stage the other
week so everyone always wants to know
how tall you are I'm like I was talking
about how short the wall is I was like
Esther or the wall taller right now
do you know what has given me a Re-Boost
of so much height confidence is that Kim
Kardashian is basically the same height
as me yeah everyone that's popular is a
little munchkin like if I that if I ever
meet her you guys like I'm gonna be
looking at her at my level I think
Prince was your height too I have seen
this is great I saw Prince at a party
once and I didn't know it was Prince but
I was like I know I know I saw him this
is like my number he's the best I saw
him walk out of a bar in Hollywood and
obviously a huge Entourage but I just
remember clocking that man is so petite
petite is so petite was he not wearing
his yeah did he have his booty did his
booty cheeks hanging out I don't know I
just remember like small person walking
by like On My Level he really did a
favor for the short Kings yeah he really
led the charge in saying hey like I'm
five foot flat but I'm gonna have a
harem I'm the hottest woman ever do you
think if he was taller he would have
named himself King
he was he just wished he could have been
like almost he was being size
appropriate
um wow we would definitely be the
Chloe's
you and I yeah oh yeah I don't think it
has to be by height but yeah I you know
what Chloe is I have to admit I watched
the new episode of the new show
Kardashians Hulu Chloe is very funny she
is they all are pretty yeah yeah well
there's always something funny happening
and yeah being sad Carlos is Kendall oh
you are Kendall you're the candle oh
he's a Rob
Rob you can work but you got to be
behind the scenes
your choice in women do resemble Blac
Chyna oh that's funny oh right yeah
because anytime you send me you know our
text messages I'm like oh he likes he
likes the beautiful thick one he likes
thicker Latino women I feel like I'm not
sent to these no this was that this was
a one night thing where where I was
actively looking for women to have sex
with
oh you sent to her yeah I remember that
yeah
[Laughter]
the gay night
it's not game night it's gay night can
we have that we should have game night
that was too serious it's every Tuesday
baby and it's during the day I don't
know if you noticed
okay so I'm gonna have to take these
hormones and so the diet that they're
gonna inject you I have to do it I'll
let Todd do it too though okay he
doesn't like to hurt me though no
you don't actually don't feel a lot you
just you make sure they said one stings
one of them really Burns they were like
we just have to be honest let's just
grab it well grab it well and grab it I
mean I do my peptides oh yeah then you
know she's used to it why does
everything you sound sounds like a 90s
hip-hop lyrics grab it well gravitate
maybe if we were around this we would
hear her say several lyrics We Have A
hip-hop album you guys were crisscross
we could guys I literally found a tick
tock that I sent to Carlos that says
Korean people don't smell they don't
they don't I'm here to tell you they
really don't not all of them do they
smell to each other maybe just our nose
cancer Koreans don't have body odor due
to a genetic mutation that alters sweat
it's not every Korean but it's it's
Bobby is one of them I can attest to
this I it angers me to no end you knew
this oh I knew this and and like his
balls Never Smell his dick never smells
unless he's like wiping back to front
and the [ __ ] accidentally gets on his
nuts but any other time I swear to you
like the boy just doesn't have to give
that caveat well is it sweat no correct
me if I'm wrong sweat
um like your bacteria farting a germ
fart is sweat even though it's Bo that's
what Bo is yeah because sweat itself
doesn't smell smell it's the bacteria
feasting on that sweat and then
producing I think your germs had some
broccoli earlier what the [ __ ]
say I feel like I don't have very I
that's a lie sometimes I don't smell but
sometimes I really do there's a
difference between workout Bo which is
hardly anything like okay
but then anxiety Bo oh my God when I'm
anxious like really nervous that's
probably your farts going into it do you
ever have a really long day of being
really really anxious and then even your
groin like you pull your panties down
and you're like [ __ ] this was a very
anxious day the smell is different
anxiety sweat is different from regular
like workout sweat I wanna like research
this on my body and figure girl are you
anxious because your [ __ ] is sexy
you ever get like when I'm nervous my
armpits are just out of control it's
wild it doesn't smell good right now
mine are I'm pinning through I'm pitting
too
when we do our hometown dates you're
gonna watch us see Philly cheese like
we're gonna do that there's a sushi spot
in Philly that I really really want to
try I think it's called royal Sushi okay
and it's only had they only have like 10
seats I think and I think it's very hard
to get
um um not an appointment a reservation
so I was hoping that maybe production
can somehow get a seat what's it called
royal I think is what it's called royal
royal oh my God why do you make
everything sound like it's like you're
like royal royal you're such a like uh
mom you know what you are you're a
forever teen you're like Mom and Dad I
love that yes you know who's a forever
teen all of us no but it was a really
good one who I used to this is where I
coined to the term was with Lisa oh
really yeah Lisa's like always she's
always like stomping up the stairs like
we made that up yeah it's not even on
the Internet it's good yeah I made it up
a forever teen
we have our forever teen moments for
sure I'm a forever teen on a plane I'm
not always a forever teen in real life
but on a plane I am I I put my socks on
I do this and honestly like no one
respects me on that plane because I look
like a child yeah I act like a child
it's like my place of like the woman
came up to us and literally I was like I
was humping Esther into the seat and the
woman came and she was like it's all
right I have good children your age I'm
like man you're 40. you definitely do
not have children
yeah we're your age [ __ ] I'm Dave's
forever teen no it's I love it it's like
it's if you've ever slammed a door
you're forever what are some other
forever teen things well I just feel
like with Dave sometimes I'm I'm a
forever teen in the house because I'm
like he's like doing this thing and I'm
gonna I'm like in my room getting high
like I'm team he doesn't want me to be
but I am if you here's a forever G move
if you you if your lock on your door is
scissors
when I was a teenager that's what was my
luck
you know I didn't have a lock on my door
either I learned it from Dazed and
Confused then they gave me a padlock and
then I just started smoking cigarettes I
was like that was a big mistake wait I
just started smoking cigarettes in my
house just blatantly like this were they
locking you in or imagine because a
padlock so I will jump out a window they
know you can smash their window they
know it's not gonna happen Esther you'd
know that pain of being locked in oh
you're locked in we're locked out the
Gated the gate locked me in you're crazy
you were created but now I'm just
picturing Annie being locked in her
bedroom and then like somehow scratching
her way through the wall and it working
100 that would happen you cannot contain
me it will not it's just not gonna
happen it's just not gonna work out they
should put you in prison as an
experiment so that they can see like the
easiest way to escape wait can I tell
you the most disrespectful custom-made
muzzles what we should have custom-made
muzzles for us you guys in high school
as okay wait in high school when I this
actually is a wild thing we can try this
on an episode it might traumatize me
though you may see a pts flare up in
front of your eyes but in high school we
had to for our graduation stuff we had
because my high school was not real they
just were there to bang us but um
one of our graduation things was you had
to do a modes of expression and people
would do like their art or whatever and
because I had been in this thing with my
teacher and everyone called me a liar
and stuff I went a whole day with my
mouth duct taped which did not last long
because I was like people were like
saying stuff and then I was pissed and
were you trying well like were you
trying to talk through the tape though
of course and then I had a mustache that
I bleached with my mom so I would that
was like our bonding was blue chair
mustaches and so then I pulled it was
like a full waxing of my upper lip but I
was so pissed and everyone was just like
it was a nightmare but
um but I I tried to have my mouth to
like as my well that's what George
Kimmel does every night he tapes his
mouth so it forces him to strictly nose
breathe because that's a healthier way
I've heard that that's like a real thing
what I heard was his wife takes that
time that opportunity when he as soon as
his mouth is taped that's when she
starts firing off we gotta send her some
idea because I have some things I need
George to do
I didn't know it was a mouth bomb I
thought it was an ears problem
wait also I think on our next live
stream we should have you tape your
mouth for like five minutes see if I can
do it and see how you see what comes out
I'm just thinking about it which means
it's a good idea do you think that you
would um be able to survive a silent
retreat
I have images of myself getting
kicked out of a silent Retreat I've
never seen it to the end in my Visions
you know I've never gotten through the
days I actually feel good for me I was
just thinking like oh should we all go
to one but I was like I
don't really go together that would be
torture to go with you guys and not be
able to talk to you would be miserable
for me you wouldn't have to be a solo
journey I would push my farts out so
loud just to communicate my loudness
wait are we allowed to laugh
no okay so and the vampasa ones because
I've looked this up I do want to do it I
just before I really wasn't
I kind of was afraid I had this weird
thought that I would like not want to do
comedy or something at the end of it
like I wasn't I was like I don't want to
do anything that would make me think
this wasn't like my dream
but I don't feel that it would that
would ever happen now no way after I've
done all this Ayahuasca and [ __ ] it's
like this is like what I meant here I'm
put here to do what if we go and then
literally within like the first by the
first day we've already figured out how
to communicate like just we have our own
language
eye contact you're not supposed to make
eye contact you can't um
you can't Journal you can't Journal oh
hell no the whole thing is about like
sitting in words to move inwards and to
have no communication and you do I think
there's like walking too like through
the day but mostly you're just sitting
there and people go crazy they're like
day four is insane you know what I'm
gonna look like in San Diego in the San
Diego Zoo
um there was an enclosed area where
there was only one sun bear and this one
bear just kept doing little circles and
I I remember
um passing by and thinking this is the
saddest most stressed out animal that's
how I would be at the silent Retreat I
would just be in circles I think I'm not
being able to do like a journal but then
you would but then you would push
through this I'm literally getting
physical manifestations of my anxiety of
like I get tingles on the side of my
face thinking about this which is making
me think we should do it I should do it
how long how many days is it 10 days so
no eye contact no um so any expression
like laughing giggling or I'm sure short
I'm sure people go into giggle fits I
can't imagine people don't just lose
their [ __ ] minds and what happens do
we get reprimanded do we get whipped
okay you're turning now
[Laughter]
um wait but okay just because we're
talking about the silent Retreat you
guys know since the day we started this
podcast all I have been wanting is to go
with you guys to the ranch Malibu boot
camp thing where they like force us to
hike they wake us up at 5am like that I
don't know this you don't no I don't no
this is like and it's it's very
expensive I think it's like literally
like seven or eight thousand dollars
that's expensive I gotta go I want this
trash podcast
but like my dream in the in life would
be to do this with you guys sometime
this calendar year okay can we do this
can we go to the ranch Malibu and have
boot camp and maybe we can record
episodes while we're there yeah wait is
that allowed like what are they yeah
it's not why don't we just do it in the
room and not tell them yeah no it would
be fine I guess it's too late we told
them they um there's like activities so
it's like from 5 a.m till 6 p.m or
whatever you're like doing the hike the
breakfast we'll never say unless she's
gonna be so far ahead of us oh that's
good our little lotto I'm gonna be the
Caboose I'm a very slow Walker and I'm a
very slow hike I'm a slow hiker really
slow and oh yeah here's like an example
of how the day goes and then she's only
going for nap time I promise you the
only reason this [ __ ] wants to go is
because she wants someone to tell her
it's okay to have nap time it's like the
high of getting to go yeah this is the
complete opposite of how you wake up
Todd in the morning look at the first
thing it said 5 30 in the morning gentle
guest wake up with Tibetan Chimes I do
cheat I do treat him like a guest I will
say that like it's my day [ __ ] some
days I wake up Dave with any energy and
it's so much fun I'm just like hi
I've been up for hours I've been waiting
for him to get up waiting he's like he's
like yeah I always wake up in in the
middle of a conversation
do this and then after dinner time we
would record our little our podcast and
check in and let everyone know how it's
going like how much fun would this be
I'm surprised it doesn't say nappy time
for Esther well we can nap time at one
o'clock how long is enough just an hour
yeah but you don't really you know you
just kind of nap time just means like
every this Ester this thing was made for
you low impact strength training
restorative I know things like gentle
and when you see how little of it I
participate in you'll really see that it
was made for me because I'm I look do
they have bathtubs is that why you love
it I think that yeah wait I'm seeing on
the bottom there's a little asterisk it
says program includes two daily snacks a
healthy cooking class Garden Tour and a
diagnostic testing I know that's what
you want you can't wait I think she owns
this place and she has I wish oh banana
break oh the prime real estate of our
podcast yeah first now for sale
foreign
Esther since you're the anti-ghost
person I think I have my very first
paranormal thing like truly happened to
me that does not make sense
um I was at the pool where I usually am
and I um usually I'll
bring my fins and I'll do these little
drills where I drop to the bottom about
10 feet and I do a couple laps
underwater right holding my breath and I
was there with my sister and while I was
underwater like on the floor just
kicking away very slowly I feel this
like someone do this something do this
so initially I was like oh it has to be
my sister yeah signaling me but then I
look up she's not there I look forward
she's on the other end of the pool and
I'm like well are is there is there
debris falling on me I was looking for
things that might have like landed on me
anything and nothing nothing Esther I
swear to you from the bottom of my heart
I thought that maybe I was either I was
having some schizophrenic moment of like
did I just imagine something touch me
that way and instead of being afraid I
actually felt really calm by it I was
like oh that's a weird thing I love that
it was underwater I know was this at
your pool like at your house no no it
was at a um a lap um the pool that I go
to lapse I'm not buying it I just feel
like a ghost would finger you you would
have somehow got molested they wouldn't
have just touched your shoulders I'm
thinking you it had to be debris there
was there was no one else in the pool
and the next Lane's over yeah I think it
was debris or someone scratching you on
accident and then quickly Esther where
I'm 10 feet in the bottom I'm under
water I'm not on the surface of the pool
I'm literally at the bottom of the pool
holding my breath kicking slowly
just doing this slowly I I'm open to
believing I want to believe am I having
a mental health crisis can we play a
clip of her screaming oh yeah
[Applause]
I would love to believe it sounds to me
like a mental health crisis no no
because I don't think there's anything
unhealthy mentally for you with this
happening because you're not scared by
it it's not bothering your life like for
me I could have something like that
happen and choose to believe that it was
like a spiritual being and that would be
okay
guys I have seven Spirit guides haven't
I told you
I have seven spirit gods I I go to this
woman she was like
she's like you have seven Spirit cards I
was like
I was like is one Dopey and one sleepy
are those seven how short are they
no I'm down for whatevs whatever works I
believe that's kind of where I'm headed
in life whatever makes me happy and
keeps me positive and enjoying things
and keeps me kind of like
um tapped into the audience and feeling
really like a community with all the
people that I meet that that's what I
believe in yeah yeah I I'm for sure like
I've lived my life being an atheist and
not having a belief in God but I always
stay open I think at some point in my
life if it goes in that direction and
now I have this newfound like belief I'd
I'd be okay with that as well yeah we
evolve it's like everything you think
when you're younger it would be but it
would be wouldn't it be weird to like
be sure of something your entire life
wouldn't that be like a sad right
experience of life right to just have
one thing yeah not be open to it
changing and like so everyone you talk
to nothing like moves you or oh yeah no
that's a good point because I love
I love talking to people and and having
that take me somewhere yeah like I love
being open to things she doesn't mean
getting kidnapped okay no we have to be
very careful with this she's very short
yeah I like you know what I like that I
used to resist when I was younger I like
being proven wrong now these days I like
being wrong I like being surprised at
how little I know about something
because that makes me so in awe of life
I'm like God I know so little like how
exciting is it that I get to learn all
of these things every day because I'm a
[ __ ] dum-dum oh yeah that it's like
my Aunt I used to be really like you
know I was brought up Quaker but not
truly religious and I was very I was an
atheist but I just wasn't I didn't
believe in God and I would you know and
I kind of was like people believe in God
like I was very like confused by the
whole thing and my aunt my uh niece
drowned when when she was four and this
is before I was born
it was before I was born my niece yeah I
mean might not many is my my cousin
um my aunt's daughter
um drowned wow and when she was four and
I remember I was talking to my my dad
had gone through open heart surgery in
2011 and my aunt came to help and we
were hanging out and my aunt was talking
about like church or God or heaven or
something and I was like I was like you
believe in God like I couldn't believe
she believed in God you believe in God
and she and she was like where else
would I see Heather and I was so now
every time someone's religious I'm like
I'm happy for you like you know what I
mean that's why I just kind of like I
really try to respect what people
believe as long as it doesn't cause harm
for other people exactly that's where
that's definitely how I've always tried
to live my life is Whatever Gets you to
lay your head down at night in a
peaceful way outside of like harming
other people intentionally you do that
and you know oh my God I'm so effective
I know and I honestly honest you know
she's my my biggest fear Annie she
passed away like when
um like she would probably be almost 50
maybe even now like I should be in her
40s and um so it was before I was born
but it was so weird like this like
birthday of hers my brother and I like
really like it was like I never like
felt it as like our family but you know
because she had been dead the whole time
and it's like one of our tribe you know
and I just feel so much for my auntie
and she's like
she has like different religion or
different um political affiliations than
my dad and sometimes they fight and I'm
like Dad it's like nothing matters like
none of that stuff and they don't like
fight fight but they like they have
decision and it's just like
everyone there's a reason why everyone
is the way they are and you're just like
gotta let them be that way again if
they're not like harming anyone but yes
yes I know I just I but I think about it
and it's like really nice to like
celebrate her birthday and stuff you
know
and I feel kind of like a [ __ ] that I
never I just never like a lot I think as
Dr Drew is saying we just like avoid
grieving on my family totally like even
when my dad was in the hospital getting
all these like surgeries and stuff and
before my dad got open heart surgery he
had stents put in to his heart and it's
it's not a huge procedure but any
procedure on your heart as you know it
causes a lot of depression it's really
intense for you because it's you can't
trust your body yeah yeah so the one
thing that has worked so diligently your
whole life that literally does not sleep
all of a sudden you're like wait could
it sleep is it gonna sleep you know your
heart just never stops beating it just
always is there you know it's there for
you every week and then you get a rhythm
is that what you had an arrhythmia an
arrhythmia my dad had that too yeah
they're [ __ ] you know my dad I
thought at one point does it keep you
short of breath or when I have my
episodes at night yeah everything's
sweating 250 beats a minute it feels
very very like you're having like the
chest pain the heart attack but Esther I
mean not to
um
um diminish in any way the drowning
incident that happened to your aunt but
I honestly now that has triggered a
thought I don't want you to drown I need
to teach you how to swim because all of
a sudden now that's a sudden fear of
mine I cannot what do you say how did
she die she drowned that would be my I I
couldn't get over that the whole show
just turns into us teaching you things
I'm totally okay with it that would be
have been the goal from the start yeah
so I'm totally fine with it can I just
please teach you Esther yes I'm so down
to learn of course we'll be sending NF
we'll be selling nfts to this experience
if but if it makes you feel better in
the meantime
I won't swim do not go anywhere near
water and my I grew up with uncles with
like you know out in the lake fishes
this is how she didn't get molested we
were in these [ __ ] swimsuits all the
time you're right we didn't ask for it
I was at home with my great grandma
while all the other kids were out having
fun with the family I was I never
participated but the chances she was
great great grandmother's pet how sad
like the senile one by the way Todd told
me that his grandmother like his whole
life had Alzheimer's so he's like every
every member of his grandmother was like
going to visit in our hospital going who
is that like he his impression is so
funny wait that happened to my sister
when my dad was when my dad was um kind
of sort of on his way out he would have
these moments of not being very lucid
and he was at home on the bed my sister
went in the room to like serve him
breakfast and then he started like he
was already in Diapers at this point
um the amount of times I have to say
that word sounds because your dad died
in diapers basically but
he started
um
um looking for his passport like he was
already bedridden at this point so he
couldn't move very much but he started
like grabbing things and then I got a
phone call because I wasn't home he
called me and he was like there is a
strange lady in my room she's kind of
hot though yeah and then your mom and I
could hear my sister over the phone
saying but but it's me like just crying
and he was like get her out of here
she's like you know she's here to like
hurt me or whatever I was like Papa
that's kawinda that's coinda and I could
hear her crying in the background and I
was like oh no he's confused but he
remembered me so I felt kind of good
about that and she was passed she's like
what the [ __ ] but it was really like
painful for her you know so like any
time I hear about like dementia is a
it's like a family Affliction it doesn't
happen to one person it happens to
everyone you know that reminds me of one
of my favorite memories of my great
grandma when we all went me and it was
she was finally like in a home and we
all went to visit her in Minnesota it
was
um her three grandchildren like my mom
her two brothers and then all the grand
the kids and
um
and she looked at all of us she didn't
know anyone except my mom and she didn't
know any of us and she just goes to my
mom where's Maury
and I was like by the way I'll say the
same thing
like where the [ __ ] is your dad [ __ ]
get the hell out of here and like I'll
always remember that because in a way it
made me feel special like it's obviously
embarrassing to me but like they didn't
remember like she didn't remember my
cousins and at least she remembered my
dad which was such a Vic like a such a
victory for me because I always felt so
insecure amongst my cousins growing up
because I was like the Jewish one and
like you're not like us and so you're
not like cousins yeah it's yeah you were
built for me you guys can make fun of
you forever you've been beat up Esther I
you know what it is I've been so ignored
like no one wanted to play with me or
hang out with me don't you know my other
things rejects me all the time it's so
annoying to hear this from the person
that rejects me goes by the way didn't
see you last night did you have to pop
out for you I literally did you check
the stage
with the microphone while I was saying
the jokes
I uh my other like famous childhood
story is that we were all at my aunt's
house in Wisconsin and all even more
cousins everyone was there and I
remember I was I couldn't find anyone I
was like and I was sitting with the
[ __ ] parents listening to them talk
like the most boring it's so funny that
she doesn't want to hang with her
parents but she wants to hang out with
the parents parents
sure just listening to the grown-ups
being boring and I was like do you guys
know where the kids are were and they
were like we don't know we don't know
and then I of course later I find out
they're all in the Attic playing
dress-up like and my sister was there
well you were Jewish they didn't want to
bring you to the Attic
curio you just sold my childhood trauma
thank you but also you I imagine just to
reframe this I imagine you were clinging
to your mom's ankle
under the ankle and you just wanted them
to be like nearer you down while you
were clinging with your like you
probably could have gone up to the attic
[ __ ] you just wanted the attic to come
to you
could be true yeah could be true yeah
but let's bully them what are their
handles
unfortunately the main ring glitter is
my [ __ ] sister oh my god well she had
to deal with you honestly yeah to be a
mother to you is so annoying a mini
mother because she's so much you just
came out dancing to like how annoying
must that have been true you like tap
dancing
literally upstaged me wait it's like are
you are you like kind of like my big
sister
um am I your big sister I'll be your big
sister I think everyone is my that's my
issues I make everyone my big sister I
treat you as a son yeah that's and I'm
slightly disappointed in we're all so
proud love that mix I believe you can do
better this is it then Dave I'm joking
she cannot Dave do not leave her room
it will be a woman you should get you
guys should dance to that maybe at your
wedding that that is it um who sings it
um The Dance With My Father song
you guys would it be really [ __ ] up if
um at my wedding I'm dancing by myself
but doing like the father-daughter dance
oh that's so good but then the Luther
Vandross song to dance with my father
again I got chills that's so funny and
good please now you have to get married
can I help you choreography like this
should be a solo can you by the way I'll
program anything you stupid [ __ ] she's
like I don't have time why because
you're dancing you're typically dancing
to teach us to dance you know that we
will do you guys manifesting Us Palm
Springs Airbnb sleepover weekend we
dance we cry we laugh we dance
we party
Carl's gets high uh we all get high like
how much fun
you guys this has been a splendid
episode I know I feel we do all have to
have weddings yes no I'm okay we're
gonna have them together because we need
to I mean mine's gonna be but Todd's
like wouldn't it be funny if we got
engaged and married and then married
before Esther I was like oh that's gonna
happen would it be funny I mean that
it's is it happening yes it's definitely
gonna happen I think you and I are in
competition for never getting there yeah
Annie needs to beat us both yeah and I
will beat us both guys I've been
thinking about weddings like I've never
thought about weddings like I kind of
want to just get married in Vegas on
purpose be the only person that's ever
on purpose got married in Vegas yeah
wouldn't that be so trashy I love that
yeah a Vegas wedding what I told the the
most memorable most heartfelt wedding I
ever went to was a really shitty wedding
of my aunts in Vegas and we were all in
club attire and I never cried harder in
my life she it was so moving
um I it was just you just felt the love
I think that's what it is when I go to
weddings a lot it feels very
transactional and you can see the bride
or the people are just very like
consumed by the experience of having to
socialize with other people it you don't
really see the love between them there's
a lot of performance yes well I was a
photographer's assistant for weddings
and she like she has to keep on a
schedule because these people will kill
her if they don't get the pictures so
she literally runs the entire wedding
because people want the pictures so bad
so that it's like like the men at the
bride and groom are having fun it's like
no no it's time for like the in-laws and
stuff like that and she's like I'm like
this is really pushy she's like Annie
they are gonna kill me if I don't do it
I what the what My Best Friend's Wedding
that we just had in great movies Texas
she the photographer was I noticed like
various sort of because they're
destroyed I think that they have the
most important job
that bums me out yeah because it's like
if I you know what if I ever have a
wedding this is the saddest thing to say
I would love literally engage wearing on
her fingers I would love to just have
the tell the photographer just [ __ ]
candidates just yeah just don't post
without showing me though documents wait
this photographer that I loved posted a
picture listen posted a picture of me
before I asked I called him I was like
dude I was like this and I had actual
camel toe in it where I was like dude do
you know how fast my followers are gonna
zoom in on my [ __ ] vagina I literally
was like we got a face tune that off
like it was like in the crack I was like
okay oh God okay let's bring back um I
think we talked about this in our
earlier episodes just like candid
ugly wedding pictures and also they're
funny when you look back at this that's
so much more fun tick tocks in Mitch
okay it's about the videographer now and
the videographer does not need to ever
have your attention right they just go
they shoot it all
right I can't wait to come to your
wedding and have it be like fully
documented like they have lights around
the fact that you think you're invited
are you gonna be a caterer you can work
I mean I assume guys your tiny tiny
hands or the ring bearer
obviously well you're the bride you're
going to be marrying Todd
there's three Brides
we should talk about that I'm into that
um you guys sell our wedding too to make
more money we'll find that people magic
spoon are we did you say magic spoon
yeah I met my wedding the cake is Magic
as well
in a little cake we have magic spoon
you guys thank you so much for listening
to this episode I hope you had as much
fun as we did
um because I feel great and also I don't
know you can come to the wedding I was
kidding it looks like it hurt you
um please subscribe to this Channel and
um comment let us know what you think
about all the stupid things we said
follow all of our Instagrams and the
trash Tuesday Instagram it's at it's
trash Tuesday yes follow it on Tick Tock
Carlos has been crushing it on Instagram
it's very funny you don't want to miss
the gems that are on there and we'll see
you guys next week we'll see you
foreign
[Music]